Hey, guys. Welcome back to the King of Random. Today, we're going to be trying an experiment
I've seen some people do before, but haven't seen very well explained.
We're going to try to be making what's called "fire snakes", a combination of burning sugar and baking soda in a base of sand.
We're gonna try a few different combinations of regular sugar,
powdered sugar, baking soda, and two different types of accelerant to see what gives us the very best results.
We've got a giant bag of sand and some metal trays to burn our sugar in, so let's get started. Now, all of my research
Indicates that it should be four parts of sugar to one part baking soda by weight.
So, that's what we're gonna do. We're gonna try three things. We're gonna have our regular sugar mixed with our baking soda.
We're going to have our powdered sugar mixed with our baking soda.
And then we're also going to try mixing some of our regular sugar with the baking soda
and then blending it up so we have an even finer powder.
We'll see how that does in comparison. We'll take all three of those mixtures and try burning each of them with alcohol and lighter
fluid and see which of our six combinations gives us the best results.
White powders everywhere...
20 grams of regular sugar. Add 5 grams of baking soda.
And except another one of the same thing which I'll blend in just a minute
One thing that might cause a different result with the powdered sugar is most powdered sugar
Actually, also has some cornstarch in it to help keep it from taking together too much
Grams or bacon
Now let's get a little blender and blend up one of the mixtures of regular sugar and baking soda
Yes unsurprisingly that now kind of looks like powdered sugar
All right, we've got our three different trays for our three different mixtures. Let's build these up with sand
My first fuel is 91% concentration of isopropyl alcohol also known as rubbing alcohol
My other one is a common barbecue lighter fluid
I'm going to pour some of each fluid on one side of the sand and
then we'll put little piles of each kind of sugar on that so overall we'll have 6 different combinations of
sugar and fuel going at once
So here we've got
Granulated sugar and alcohol is the fuel here?
We've got granulated sugar and lighter fluid as a fuel blend and sugar with alcohol when it's your lighter fluid powdered sugar
alcohol powdered sugar lightest
A little harder time getting the lighter fluid delight than the alcohol, so that's one point for alcohol
That when it lit well
Here we go
So let's take a little bit of a look at what is happening here as the sugar burns
it bubbles and boils and turns black and turns into just basically carbon some of the gas is being led off by the
Baking soda are actually filling the molten sugar as its creative
It doesn't just turn into a puddle of black sugar it turns into a sort of expanded foam of black sugar
Well here we go here's the results of our test the powdered sugar
definitely started making the fire snakes the fastest they took off pretty quickly the
powdered sugar with the lighter fluid never got very far
We only got this one little weird stumpy thing which still looks pretty cool
But it's not very big you can see most of the sugar is still just kind of there
clumps together
another interesting point something
I want to talk about is that if you've seen videos of this before it doesn't occur to you
How unbelievably lightweight this stuff is because you have a pile of sugar
that's all of the mass and then it's just expanded out to this large snake, so this thing weighs almost nothing is like styrofoam because
It's also incredibly fragile look at this it just
Comes right apart you can see how light and fluffy it is inside then if I crush it
Basically just turns into dust I'm solid you just watch dust fly up off of it
Powdered sugar with alcohol that one worked great it started off very quickly it kept going for quite a while
There is still a lump of unburned sugar down at the bottom
But it's pretty small it really got most of it
That grew and twist it around and we got like a secondary growth coming off of it at one point. I'm pretty good
That's a lot of big black snake curls wonderfully
There's I don't know if you can get to some cameras even a little bits of
Iridescent sort of colored going through parts of this so it's pretty neat
So powdered sugar with alcohol is a fuel that works really well our blended sugar well our blended sugar with the lighter fluid
Got basically nowhere
Almost all the sugar
Mixed with the baking soda is still here didn't burn
We got a little bit of result, but not a lot blended sugar with the alcohol
It took a while, and then it did start growing, but it didn't get very far
It's not bad that does kind of look like a cool demon horn some sort of cancerous sand growth or something
Not bad
granulated sugar with lighter fluid
again, not very impressive
I took this piece off to try and let some of the sugar inside get a little more access to the heat
Didn't really seem to do much
This still looks cool, but it's very small. It didn't go very far
I'm actually gonna try eating a tiny bit of this and it's gonna taste terrible
I'm hoping this inner part will just taste like burnt sugar, and it won't all taste just like carbon
There's also baking soda in it so it's like salty burn sugar no
Yeah
It's terrible
granulated sugar and alcohol this took a good while to
Start doing anything like it it took a long time for it to get beyond just this first little bit
But eventually it started growing really well, and it just kept going until even though it is very lightweight
Eventually I had enough weight to just break a piece off and then it started making another piece and the mountain broke off and then
Another piece for it came and that broke off
And it's just kept on going so I think we definitely got the most volume out of the granulated sugar
Eventually the the powdered sugar definitely took off faster
But in the end, I think the granulated sugar was the most firesnake you at all
Oh, it's pretty close tie between those two I actually liked both of them pretty well
But I'm gonna say the granulated sugar with my favorite. Just because it kept going and diminishing and getting smaller and smaller
I think it's pretty clear that the 91% isopropyl alcohol that we were using is a much better fuel than the lighter fluid
so
Isopropyl alcohol very good granulated sugar or powdered sugar both quite good
Blended sugar not really so good, so we're not going to use that anymore well
I'm gonna clean this up, and then I have a couple ideas of how to scale this up to something a little bit larger
It just disappears
I'm gonna use our powdered sugar mix for this one because it started going
Fastest and use the alcohol of course because that works way better
And I'm just gonna set up like a whole bunch of different spots on one tray of sand I'm gonna
Hope they kind of grow together
into one giant
Fire flame smoke log. We'll see what happens
All right, oh, it's good. Let's light it up
Lit and it's good
That was pretty cool
It wasn't exactly what I was hoping for I was hoping for we just kind of get like a large
Column of this stuff rising up and that didn't really work out, but it did get some good volume
We got quite a bit of the black snake material, which looked a little bit cooler well
It's still on the tray make a couple of times. I cleared it off
So we could like let the new stuff go in without all the weight of what was on there crushing it down overall
pretty neat
I've got one more thing that I want to try
And it's gonna take up a little more space for
All these ins I am using the powdered sugar rather than the granulated sugar just because it starts going
Faster still think the granulated sugar might be better for a total result in getting the biggest longest snakes
I just didn't want to wait for it this time
Now we've got 13 fire snakes going at once
I've spread them out a little bit more so that they hopefully won't bond together like they were in the last one this way
I'm hoping we just get 13 different snakes rising a foot or two off of the tray
Well there we go
13 different black snakes all in one tray all together making this sort of weird twisted field of gnarled growing things
I don't even know what to call them, but that looks pretty cool
It was fun to do and guys this experiment is so
easy powdered sugar baking soda and rubbing alcohol
You just put that in a little bit of sand and light it
And you get this it's like the cheapest experiment you could ever do and it looks so cool
I found that I had really good results using both granulated sugar and powdered sugar the powdered sugar started working a little bit faster the
Granulated sugar kept going longer, so you kind of have to choose, which one you prefer
I definitely found that the 91% rubbing alcohol worked better as a fuel than the lighter fluid. I think it started better
I think it burned more consistently and
Just gave us better results in the end if you're trying this at home make sure you're doing it in place with good ventilation
Make sure you're not gonna light anything on fire around you and you have proper safety equipment to put anything out
But this is absolutely something you can do at home
Thanks for joining us for this project today, and we'll see you in the next one talk to you then
And now I'm gonna see how quickly I can vacuum all of this up, so it's just go on
Probably the most satisfying thing to vacuum that I've ever vacuumed
Hey guys
I know there are so many great videos and great youtubers out there that you could be watching
Instead of the king of random, I just want to say how grateful. I am that you choose to watch us